la rentrée c'est aussi l'heure des
bilans c'était le cas ce matin pour la
saison touristique et l'optimisme est de
mise
les touristes étrangers continuent à
apprécier l'ile-de-france et les
professionnels eux se frottent les mains
béatrice casanova il de wulf plus de 4
millions de touristes ont visité l'île
de france cet été
c'est la première fois qu'ils sont si
nombreux en cette saison
paris reste le site le plus visité la
tour eiffel notre dame les champs
elysées et le louvre attire toujours
autant les foules mais les autres
départements profitent aussi de cet
afflux de tourisme
le stade de france à saint-denis le parc
disney à marne la vallée
auvers-sur-oise ou bien encore
fontainebleau font de plus en plus
partie des tchèques touristique en été
ce sont les étrangers qui visitent le
plus la région cette année une forte
augmentation des américains elle y est
bien sûr la très bonne tenue du dollar
face à l'euro à une bonne conjoncture
économique internationale mais également
les britanniques les allemands donc des
clientèles lointaines des japonais
reviennent après avoir surmonté la crise
monétaire et financière d'extrême orient
mais également les sud américains les
canadiens
et puis les clients thèse de l'est
russes et chinois qui apparaît de plus
en plus nombreux les professionnels du
tourisme se frottent les mains
la saison fut bonne et l'île de france
s'en portait bien
le tourisme c'est aujourd'hui en ile de
france plus de 220 milliards de francs
de chiffre d'affaires ce qui fait du
tourisme est la deuxième activité
économique de la région
il y en ile-de-france 750 mille emplois
liés au tourisme avec 24 millions de
visiteurs par an l'île de france reste
la région la plus visitée du monde